[Music]
what is the funniest thing on the planet
that's right
face swaps aimsley go hilarious what if
I told you there was a bot that will do
this for you what if I told you about
the greatest bottom all time but that
lets you face wall
it's called project Murphy and you can
ask it anything we finally done it the
science has mastered it we could use
this for greater good of mankind we
could ask you anything now let's ask
what if keemstar
[Music]
excuse me I think it's a valid question
don't you think aimsley easy thank you
very much for backing me up on that one
what if leafy had a chin don't II do it
don't you good tonight
I know it is dangerous in sleep why
would I have to know why did Hitler show
up I'm not joking what the [ __ ] is that
I knew I knew I knew it I knew it I keep
saying it but no one listens come on I
need to know for science there we go I
know it I know it
what if Hitler was good
[Music]
everything would be different what if
jacksepticeye was funny
hahaha you never know what you're gonna
get you never know what you're gonna get
okay here we go
what if surah Shah was a vegan hmm how
about that remember they're vegan girl
so [ __ ] what if she was actually a
vegan the [ __ ] is this where is she
oh why let me try that again
give me another option come on the [ __ ]
are you doing oh now that's a really
good Face Swap really really that is
[ __ ] terrifying what the [ __ ]
happened there thanks Lee do something
now this this question paints me
but what if Harambee was to lag
[Music]
that's Leslie Jones no no Leslie Jones
is not a Robbie Paisley
Leslie Jones is not Haram assayer why is
Leslie Jones God no God no not Leslie
jumps let's try again but if Harambee
was Jesus is this some kind of joke
that's pretty sexy you know what [ __ ]
Marzia I would [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ]
oh wait is jacksepticeye goddamnit
Leslie Jones for [ __ ] sake okay can
you just nine that is Leslie Jones on a
white man's face that is racist I am
triggered [ __ ] you
god dammit god [ __ ] damn god damn
this is proof there is no God I know
marina Joyce was she kidnapped
what if marina Joyce was kidnapped the
pupils really does the trick doesn't it
we got sidetracked we need this for
humankind
what if Trump was president that is so
wrong on so many levels okay here's the
question everyone's asking what if Peter
Pyle was good
[Music]
all right I hope you enjoyed this video
um Aynsley is quitting we had a good run
didn't we Ainsley now I left a Twitter
poll of who should replace Ainsley so
leave a leave a comment down below
Ainsley we wish you best of luck in the
future on your future endeavors
wherever you will go we support you and
of course you're welcome back anytime
you want Ainsley I hope you have a great
time and that maybe one day you will you
will find what you want to do in life
and feel free to say hi you know any
time grab a grab a beer something like
that we wish you best of luck everyone
wish Ainsley best of luck in the future
and yeah love you guys so much and I'll
see Bruce in the next video stay us go
you should watch cowspiracy because it's
a very good thing to watch but it's very
gory so I don't recommend watching it
but just understand we repeat that you
should watch cowspiracy because it's a
very good thing to watch but it's very
gory so I don't recommend watching it
damn let's go here we didn't figure out
10 minute mark yet so we ended the video
a little too early that's okay